merci beaucoup de mains bah quoi ses
ventes pour amasser voter tout seul mais
c'est un meuble au cas où vous l'auriez
pas remarqué
je suis pressé vous pouvez réappuyé sur
le bouton du rez de chaussée
non je peux pas je suis aveugle au cas
où vous l'auriez pas remarqué quoi ces
mois là de quoi mais c'est sorti comme
ça je sais pas si mon attention parce
que sur votre gauche il ya des pots
voilà un athérosclérose en fait c'est
comme un infarctus sauf que c'est pas au
coeur c'est la routine quoi c'est je
crois pas du tout vous allez rester
longtemps aveugle c'est un fait que ça
soit sérieux non vous êtes vraiment la
parano de services en a league est
revenu au caire david est
particulièrement dure pour vous vous n'y
voyez rien vous êtes seul au monde ça
vous importants ce qui va vous sauver la
lumière divine vous êtes vraiment grave
au sein tous les deux nous allons aussi
nous avec ça
raté j'aimerais bien je te demandais
quelque chose il faut comme un comme un
cavalier grecque
tu correction cheval au petit matin sur
la plage at-elle
pourquoi il est aussi infect avec ma
soeur l'a pas encore compris mais
l'amour ça fait mal ça déchire le coeur
sa griffe saluons route pas avec ses
biens
ce silence
oh